I've been saying on my show for quite
some time now but I think it's really
ramped up since October 7th that the one
group of people that it seems to me
really could switch parties right now
are the disaffected libs like what
what's the messaging that Republicans
should be doing on that one of my best
friends in this world in 20120 was out
there literally campaigning for Joe
Biden so this same woman just take for
her for an example kids in New York City
School Co hit they shut her schools down
for over a year finally went to an open
the schools rally you know what happened
happened she was called a white
supremacist by a bunch of protesters who
were standing there that's when I saw
the light bulb go on and then it started
a spiral from there you know like her
kids not being able to play basketball
unless they were double vaxed at age 13
but for people who are not ready to pull
the lever for a republican because of
branding um you don't have to you can be
where I am you can be a registered
independent you can just vote like a
like a sane person and be free to call
out the nonsense on both sides